[Music]
they arrive in silence and darkness
they descend from the skies and have a
hunger for human flesh
they are
parasites
upon infecting their victims they can
take upon many forms winged creatures
monsters with blades for hands but most
disguise themselves behind the mask of
the human hosts they control
and thus no one knows who is a parasite
and who isn't fear of knowing you might
be eaten by the person standing next to
you
infects everyone's mind
this is the case for all except for
shinji izumi an ordinary high school
student who gets his right hand turned
into the home of a parasite after its
invasion of his brain goes wrong
giving him the ability to sense and be
sensed by parasites but only an arms
worth of their fighting strength
battling for control of his own body and
against the parasites who threatened
humanity it is up to shinichi to try and
maintain the fragile balance of the
world after humans are faced with a
species stronger than them in nearly
every way imaginable
parasite has always been one of my
favorite anime since i first watched it
many years ago it has one of the
greatest protagonist character
development arcs i've seen to this day
through shinichi
it has action scenes between such fast
and lethal opponents that you find
yourself holding your breath and only
releasing it once the battle leaves at
least one mangled corpse
it has tearjerker moments that make you
question humanity itself
and an incredibly iconic ost to top it
all off
however something i noticed most of all
through my numerous re-watches of
parasite over the years
is that i discover something new every
time
maybe just a small detail an important
line i forgot or even just the look in a
character's eye but i always manage to
peel back another layer of this complex
investigation into the human species
that masquerades itself as a simple
horror story
and after four re-watches of this
beautiful anime i decided that it was
finally time to read the manga as well
because if i was already finding new my
new details with every re-watch
i figured there must be a trove of
details that were lost in translation
when converting from the manga
the details that iwaki hitoshi drew so
many decades ago that have gone
forgotten
and the first thing i found particularly
interesting about parasites specifically
before i even began delving into the
manga chapters themselves
is its two different names
the name of the original manga
and the name of the anime
[Music]
the original manga of parasite first
published in 1989 is simply called
kiseju or parasite but actually there's
a layer of depth in the name itself that
goes unseen to anyone unfamiliar with
japanese and the kanji characters they
use
the actual word for parasite in japanese
is kisechu a small difference in
pronunciation yes but a huge difference
in meaning
this last character in the word for
parasite pronounced mushy on its own is
the character in japanese for insects
and my new life forms pertaining to
bacteria and parasites but instead of
using the normal character in the title
of his manga hitoshi iwaki replaced this
last kanji with kimono or shishi or in
its english translation
a beast
and the name of the anime adds something
to its title is parasite the maxim
now a maxim is a short broad statement
expressing a general truth a proverb the
kind of pithy statement that
philosophers of yore also loved to
indulge in
and it is important to note that rarely
if ever do anime change the name of the
manga when adapting it especially if the
translation is just one word and as
simple as parasite
even if they wanted to honor the change
in kanji character in the anime title as
well the maxim is clearly unrelated to
that purpose it's extraneous
and so it's addition to the title
invites a key question
why is it there
in my eyes it stands to reason that the
need to add the maxim to the anime title
was so important in representing the
ideas that parasite dives into that the
production company was willing to
completely alter the meaning of the
title for the sake of the maxim's
inclusion
and i believe i'm right in this
assumption
because while the original name of the
manga is only a little bit more than a
play on words kiseiyu vs kiseichu a
minute life form versus a brutish beast
parasite the maxim introduces a new idea
entirely in just its three-word
title a maxim is a fundamental principle
a fact
but one that up to this point had to
have been created by humans
a fabricated truth of the universe which
is only founded on what humans believe
what we can comprehend
and no i don't mean to question ancient
philosophy or established facts of the
world
because parasite the maxim already does
it in my stead
behind the gore the shape-shifting the
horror of it all
parasite exposes humanity's faults
the moral standards and so-called laws
we have set as a race to justify
ourselves and how quickly those same
truths fall apart once we are threatened
when faced with a true maxim and
parasites come to earth to impose that
onto humans we see how humanity's maxims
are filled with hypocrisy in the face of
undeniable fear
to sum up all of that philosophical
jargon that i just said parasite pulls
off an incredibly difficult task and
does it subtly
underneath the surface of this classic
horror story it manages to make
murderous emotionless aliens feel like
the good guys compared to humans our own
race
this strange contradiction is what i
will investigate today in this video in
what i have described as the beauty
behind the madness
now in this video i will continue on the
assumption that you have already seen
parasite or have at least an idea of
what it's about
and though i don't think there will be
significant spoilers as this is more of
a broad discussion of the series themes
and message
i won't be going out of my way to
necessarily avoid them
now let's
get into it
i thought there would be a trove of
details in the manga that the anime
missed and i immediately realized that i
wasn't wrong
see the anime opens by saying a single
line
someone on earth had a passing thought
before proceeding to see this poor woman
get brutally decapitated by her
parasitic husband
the show very quickly leaned into the
horror aspect reels in its watchers with
the gore and the shock factor but the
manga's very first pages have an
entirely different feeling to them than
the beginning of the anime
see that first line that was in the
anime was only the first of many that
were supposed to preface the
decapitation scene in the manga
the real chapter goes like this
above earth someone was thinking
if half of mankind disappeared how many
forests would be saved
if 99 of mankind disappeared
would pollution be reduced by 99
someone was thinking if we protected
life
it has a completely new meaning
the manga makes two things clear from
the beginning
that humanity is a plague to earth
itself
and the implication that there exists a
higher power in this story that decides
to send the parasites to punish them for
it
in the first two pages it establishes
the maxim that the anime felt was
integral to its title that maxim being
that life must be protected something we
see very often repeated throughout the
anime and the manga
these are the first lines of parasite
almost as if to say that no matter where
the story might go how the characters
might change it all comes back to this
idea that started it all
and the irony of it is that the only
real hindrance to protecting life
is the human race
it suggests that perhaps ki seiju the
parasitic beast does not refer to the
small life forms that arrive on earth
but actually the dangerous hosts they
inhabit
humans
iwaki hitoshi says with only the title
of this manga and its first two pages
that we are the real parasites of the
world
these new parasites invade humans and
eat us to survive yes but we are no
different
we as a species inhabit earth and
continue to harm it as we deprive it of
its nutrients and natural resources and
not only does the manga say this but it
also argues that we're even worse
because unlike the parasites who
strictly eat humans we harm and take
advantage of every species
humans have a history of hunting
domesticating and breeding just about
every animal to exist so who are we to
play the victim when we as humans
have done far worse than the parasites
and continue to do so
but of course this isn't a history
lesson and neither is parasite
talking about the bad humans have done
isn't very interesting or worth telling
at all every human on this planet is
well aware of the harm we've done and
the animals we eat that alone is not
worth making a fictional story about
and as such parasite reveals this
hypocrisy of humankind not by saying
what we've done going into the history
of it all
but by showing how people willfully
ignore those horrors we ourselves have
done as a species
parasite is a horror manga through and
through
but what is so scary about parasite is
not at all the gore or the killing in my
opinion the real horror is just how
truthfully it exposes the side of
humanity we are afraid to admit exists
let me explain
parasites in a way act as a voice of
reason in this manga yes it's it's true
they are unfamiliar with societal
customs they don't understand why humans
act the way they do
so in a way they are this unbiased party
who can see human morals for what they
are
contradictory
parasites are killing humans yes but
megi mentions how humans have killed
each other a lot more than parasites
have
war serial killers who murder not even
to feed but just for their own
satisfaction
miggy's right
when the bullies in the park are
throwing rocks at a cat shinji screams
out how living animals are not our toys
and that they feel pain
but as another parasite mentions
humans kill cows and pigs and don't feel
remorse or fear
but when it comes to their own kind the
parasites are framed as devils in our
midst for doing the same
it just so happens that we are there
cows and pigs
so where do we draw the line when is
killing humans okay when is hunting
animals okay
and when is it not
see this is part of the madness there is
no answer if you thought i could give
you one humanity has grown so large and
made so many exceptions that you can
never be completely good or bad with
what you do you pick sides
you eat meat or you don't you cast a
vote for a mare who wants to preserve
the environment indirectly advocate for
the good of the planet or you don't
you think that parasites are just trying
to co-exist eat in hiding to make sure
they aren't hunted by humans just like
every other species on earth
or you don't
and even though i can't answer this on
my own i think that parasite actually
does try to draw this line and make it
clear what humans think is acceptable
what meets their standards
and it almost always stems from the
presence
of human emotion
the most important theme in the anime
stayed true in the manga when i read it
or the other way around i guess
that theme being the importance of human
emotion
starting with migi in nearly every
encounter with parasites their lack of
emotion is almost always a topic of
discussion migi wanting to use the
students as a meat shield against mr a
tamiya using her baby as a living
experiment
even more so than being able to turn
into a living weapon what feels the most
inhumane about parasites what shinichi
takes the most offense to is that they
are everything a human is the appearance
the speech
but they have none of the emotion
and this is why shinji's character arc
is so much more heartbreaking as he
slowly turns into
what scares him and the manga often uses
shinichi's eyes what are generally known
as the window into the soul as a vehicle
to show this gradual loss of feeling his
parasitification if you will
in many of shinichi's most heartfelt
moments of inner turmoil the look in his
eyes is emphasized
the first tear he sheds after his mother
dies
when he sees hideo shimada's massacre in
the school and the countless bodies of
his former classmates there is a reason
why the window into the soul and to the
heart of shinichi
always becomes a point of attention in
this manga's most important moments
it's because once again instead of
really focusing on the gore and horror
of this story
what is paramount in those scenes is
understanding how it makes shinichi feel
shinichi is the perfect middleman of
this story as he's the only person who
can try and understand both sides humans
and parasites
he is bothered by parasite's lack of
emotion because he internally knows that
having emotions feeling sad crying are
the only things that still keep him on
the precipice of being human
and the manga and anime most accurately
pinpoint this single trait that divides
human from the emotionless parasites as
altruism
altruism is the belief in or practice of
disinterested and selfless concern for
the well-being of others
the manga describes it as the opposite
of selfishness
and there is essentially an entire
chapter in the manga where tamiya
listens in on a professor lecturing
about altruism before she meets shinichi
it only makes sense that the one
parasite who genuinely shows a semblance
of interest in becoming human or at
least melding with their society to the
best of her abilities is attending a
lecture on altruism a trait that humans
hold very dearly
just look at morano's shock at shinichi
throwing the dead dog in the trash can
or shinichi's classmates fear after
seeing him calm down in only 10 seconds
after witnessing dozens of their friends
corpses
being troubled for the sake of others is
what mighty even describes as what it
means to be human
but the professor in that lecture notes
that it's a practice that isn't
exclusive to us
many animals protect their offsprings or
frequently sacrifice themselves to
ensure the survival of a group bees
sacrifice their lives to defend their
nests despite being incapable of what
humans describe as thought
most life forms exhibit altruism in one
way or another
and to contrast this something that is
made clear repeatedly throughout the
story is that the parasite's paramount
priority is self-preservation
the true opposite of altruism that they
don't have a shred of care inside them
for others
this class lecture in parasite is
particularly noteworthy because it is
one of the few topics that does suggest
that humans are justified in this story
the opposite of parasite's larger theme
that i mentioned earlier
it's difficult to argue for altruism as
a bad trait to have and if it is the one
thing separating us from the parasites
doesn't that make us morally right
well
not quite
because once again behind the debates
between migi and shinichi his
emotionless moments that shock us and
make us believe he's losing his humanity
there lies a simple truth that refers
back to what i was saying about
humanity's willful ignorance
that they internally disregard the
altruism that parasites do in fact
exhibit
to maintain their image as villains and
parasitic beasts
we must once again consider the
parasite's overall purpose for being on
earth it suggested that they were sent
from a higher power to protect life
they came to earth to defend it from
human harm
a parasite ran for governor in the story
and was elected by humans on his
platform to preserve the environment
a parasite was able to resemble a human
so well that people voted for him he
easily garnered their trust in the ideas
and feelings he expressed
with no doubt if he suggested the same
ideas in monster form no one would trust
him he wouldn't be voted in
but it's ironic that shinichi always
claims they have no emotion but he has
no way of disputing or correcting them
they are right
no matter how much we want to call them
aliens or emotionless this demonstrates
that human thoughts like altruism are
not exclusive to our species
to claim altruism as a distinctly human
trait is arrogant parasites want to
preserve the world tamiya shows care for
her child before her death migi
sacrifices himself for shinichi
it just so happens that because they eat
humans any good they might do is
considered irrelevant
they evidently want to coexist with
humans by hiding how they eat us and
even disguising their appearances to fit
our standards
but shinichi finds the idea of
coexistence
repulsive yet humans coexist with pigs
and cows and eat them
it's
the same
but humans try so hard to refuse that
fact
my favorite line from the ending of
parasite goes something like this
first one species must understand that
it cannot fully comprehend another
it's incredible how pretentious man can
be
to think it has power over every living
being
by the end of the story it could be said
that both sides end up winning in some
way humans can live out their lives
without worrying about being eaten and
parasites are able to coexist with
humans
and at the end with mig's disappearance
almost like it was all a dream and
parasite's integration in society and
disappearance in a way it essentially
ends exactly where the story began
but a lot happens
parasites giving birth to human children
serial killers ordering the police to
kill dozens of innocent people parasites
running for mayor the madness of a
fearful society
and despite it all the monsters that
devour flesh and can massacre dozens of
humans in a mere second who we should
instinctively be scared of
are the ones we end up supporting
humans and the reader themselves learn a
valuable lesson that we have no right to
impose our maxims and laws our moral
upstanding as the quote-unquote most
altruistic beings to exist
on earth and its other inhabitants
and to be able to create such a complex
theme amidst an incredibly entertaining
suspenseful emotional and horrific story
is beautiful
and that is the beauty behind the
madness
of parasite the maxim
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses
you